they do is they allow us to switch from
a double angle C to theta to a single
theta single angle one theta so you can
see these are just identities you can go
from the right side to the left side and
condense or you can expand this from the
left side to the right side these are
equivalent but what we're doing here is
we're just again like I said writing the
angle from a double angle in terms of a
single angle so these are the formulas
we're going to be using sine of two
theta equals two sine theta cosine theta
tangent of two theta equals two tangent
theta divided by one minus tangent
squared theta and then cosine 2 theta
actually has three different forms and
that's because of the Pythagorean trig
identity sine squared plus cosine
squared equals one so if you know one of
these you can derive the other two so
those are the formulas we're gonna be
using so let's take a triangle over here
this angle is theta one theta and we've
got five 12 if we do the Pythagorean
theorem we can solve for that missing
side 13
okay now let's find out what's cosine of
two times this angle so imagine this
angle was doubled so now would be summer
like you know twice as large okay so
cosine of two theta let's use this top
formula cosine squared theta minus sine
squared theta so that's going to be
cosine squared theta minus sine squared
theta cosine is adjacent over hypotenuse
so that's 12 thirteenth's
squared minus the sine of theta which is
opposite over hypotenuse that's 513
squared and if we simplify that we get
144 over 169 minus 25 over 169 which
equals 119 over one six nine okay so
that's an exact answer sine of two theta
we're gonna use this top one here so we
have two sine theta times the cosine of
theta sine is opposite over hypotenuse
so that's 513
times 2 which is 2 over 1 cosine theta
which is adjacent over hypotenuse that's
12 thirteenth's and then all we have to
do is multiply across so that gives us
60 120 over 169 okay now if we want to
find out tangent of two theta we have a
couple of choices we can use the tangent
formula here or we can take sine divided
by cosine so tangent of two theta is the
same as sine over cosine sine of two
theta over cosine of two theta so if we
do that that's going to be a 120 divided
by 119 and you can see if we multiply
the numerator and denominator by 169
we're just going to end up with 120 over
119 so if you want to double check your
work you might want to do the tan in
double angle formula and just verify
that you're getting the same result if
not you can go back and check the sine
and the cosine okay now the next ones
we're going to take a look at our how to
rewrite some of these expressions using
the double angle formula so what's
happening here again just focusing on
the fact that these are identities
they're identical the left on the right
sides if they give us something that
looks like the right side we can rewrite
it okay in terms of the left side so
what we're going to do here is look at
this formula eight sine X cosine X which
one does that look like looks like the
top one right so what we're going to do
is we're going to say well this isn't
exactly like that but if we factor out a
four four times two is eight and so now
we have two sine X cosine X which is the
same as sine of two x times this four
so there you go we've just rewritten the
expression using a double angle instead
of a single angle we went from the right
side to the left side okay this next one
10 cosine squared X minus 5 which one
does that look like that one looks like
this one here in the middle this is the
cosine double angle formula so what we
have here is we're going to factor out a
5 so that's 2 cosine squared X minus 1
okay and we know 2 cosine squared X
minus 1 is cosine of 2 X so this is just
going to be 5 times the cosine of 2 X
okay so there again we're just going
from the right side to the left side
going from single angle to a double
angle using the identities okay these
last two examples I want to show you
we're going to be solving trig equations
you can see there's a double angle in
here as well as a single angle so how
can we work with that well for this one
why don't we use our double angle
formula and expand it out so this is
going to be 2 sine X cosine X minus sine
X okay that's the sine X and then what
we can do is we can factor and set the
factors equal to 0 so I'm just going to
factor out a sine because that's in
common in both groups so sine of X
equals 2 cosine X minus 1 and then what
we can do is we can set each group equal
to 0 so this is going to give a sine of
x equals 0 and if you set this one is 0
we're going to get cosine x equals 1/2
cosine x equals 1/2 we're just adding
the 1 and dividing by 2 so now we go to
our unit circle where to sign equals 0
sine equals 0 over here at 0 and pi okay
so 0 PI and we're just cosine equal 1/2
cosine equals 1/2 here at PI over 3 and
5 PI over 3 and if you need help with
that go back to my video on the unit
circle and review that but if you really
know your unit circle really well you'll
be able to find these angle
so that's that one it's zero PI pi over
3 and 5 PI over 3 that's just from 0 to
2 pi once around the unit circle okay in
the last example cosine 2x plus sine X
we're going to use the cosine double
angle formula but here's the question
which one should we use should we use
the first one the second one the third
one well it doesn't really matter but if
you make a good decision we'll make the
work a little bit easier let's go with
this bottom one this way we can get
everything in terms of sines see how
this is cosine 2x and this is sine X
we're gonna get this cosine 2x in terms
of sine so that's going to be let's give
ourselves a little bit more room here so
that's going to be 1 minus 2 sine
squared X plus sine X equals 0 I'm going
to write this in descending order
negative 2 sine squared X plus sine X
plus 1 equals 0 this is a trinomial it's
a quadratic form and what we're gonna do
is we're going to factor it so negative
2 sine X and positive sine X and we've
got negative 1 and negative 1 so that
factors and then what we do we set each
group to 0 so we get sine equals 1 and
we get sine equals negative 1/2 ok now
we're two sine equal negative one half
and one well we know sine is one here at
PI over 2 and we know sine equals
negative 1/2 in the third and fourth
quadrants at 7 PI over 6 and 11 PI over
6